come sarà l'agricoltura di domani che
cosa coltiveremo domani che cosa
mangeremo domani e partiamo da alcuni
numeri per dare qualche risposta
la fauci dice che nel 2050 saremo 9,1
miliardi di persone a vivere su questo
pianeta ci dice che saremo il 70 per
cento residenti in città e tutte queste
persone ovviamente mangiano consumano
cosa significa 9,1 miliardi di persone
significa il 70 per cento di cibo in più
di oggi 70 per cento cosa ci dice è poco
insomma un numero una percentuale
proviamo immaginarci questa percentuale
questa percentuale sono giusto per fare
un esempio 3 miliardi di tonnellate di
cereali 470 milioni di tonnellate di
carne
ve l'immaginate 470 milioni tonnellate
di carne un sacco
in più oltre questa crescita continua
incessante c'è il clima che cambia e noi
sappiamo che la temperatura del globo è
aumentata sta aumentando e più
temperatura significa più energia
nell'atmosfera significa più movimenti
nell'atmosfera e quindi assistiamo a un
maggior numero di eventi estremi piogge
torrenziali periodi di siccità periodi
in cui abbiamo 20 grandine e chiaramente
tutti questi eventi cosa fanno mettono
in difficoltà la nostra produzione
la temperatura si alza ci fa guadagnare
anche qualche area coltivabile nelle
zone più a nord nelle zone più fredde
nelle zone più alte però di fronte a
questo guadagno perdiamo molte aree
coltivabili soprattutto nelle zone più
aride la desertificazione avanza e già
oggi il bilancio di guadagno e di
perdita sta diventando negativo e quindi
insomma
torniamo un po a questi numeri no 470
milioni di tonnellate di carne ma vi
immaginate quante vacche quanti polli
quanti maiali sono 470 milioni di
tonnellate di carne
e dove li mettiamo tutti
uno può pensare camera dei bambini
camera degli ospiti
tanto poi i figli non ne facciamo più e
gli amici li troviamo sui social e 3
miliardi di tonnellate di cereali un
sacco di terra dobbiamo rinunciare ai
campi di calcio per coltivare cereali ma
forse no e perché ovviamente
l'agricoltura cambierà
come cambia anche la popolazione
torniamo ai numeri 9 miliardi
la maggior parte sta in città
cosa significa significa che ci saranno
dei centri di consumo molto concentrati
dove c'è ricerca richiesta di cibo e
ovviamente questo cibo alla diversità
già noi oggi possiamo immaginarci noi
vogliamo fare una semplificazione eco
pensiamo ci sono degli alimenti che sono
facilmente conservabili facilmente
trasformabili che si possono trasportare
con facilità
ecco questi alimenti molto probabilmente
continueranno essere prodotti nelle zone
agricole attuali però c'è tutta una
categoria di alimenti quelli freschi
facilmente deperibili pensiamo solo alle
lattuga le insalate alle cicorie e
questi bisogna produrli vicino dove si
consumano il trasporto diventa complesso
soprattutto quando pensiamo a città che
ospitano milioni di abitanti ed ecco che
qui abbiamo degli strumenti che saranno
l'attualità di domani la coltivazione
idroponica che cosa significa
significa che mi distacco dalla
coltivazione in suolo e produco le
piante
su una soluzione di acqua e sali
minerali e se invece di usare una
soluzione uso naro soul o la
coltivazione aereo pollica e questo mi
permette dico di coltivare senza suolo
quindi posso risparmiare sulla risorsa
suolo e posso avere la produzione vicino
ai centri di consumo ma ovviamente siamo
tanti in città e anche le serre insomma
hanno una certa superficie ecco che
allora abbiamo il cosiddetto vertical
farming dove produciamo in verticale
immaginatevi tanti vassoi uno sopra
l'altro pieni di piante di insalata che
stanno crescendo le serre però vanno
riscaldate d'inverno vanno raffreddate
d'estate e quindi anche qui risorse
allora una possibilità che vedremo sarà
la coltivazione indoor che significa un
ambiente isolato termicamente dove delle
luci led a basso consumo produrranno
delle lunghezze d'onda esattamente nella
parte che le piante utilizzano per la
loro fotosintesi
però abbiamo sappiamo che la popolazione
sta invecchiando è una popolazione
sedentaria non ci muoviamo più e siamo
molto attenti alla salute quindi cambia
la dieta avete mai pensato che
coltura i cibi che mangiamo oggi sono
frutto di una selezione di esigenze del
passato nel medioevo non avevamo
trasporti non avevamo la macchina e
dovevamo fare tutto a mano non c'era
riscaldamento e poi non c'era neanche
frigorifero le tecnologie per conservare
gli alimenti e quindi cos'è che abbiamo
sviluppato selezionato nel corso degli
anni i cereali i legumi i semi oleosi
pensate quelle cose che oggi ci mandano
in crisi perché poi tutto queste calorie
si accumulano nei punti dove non
vogliamo tutto questo era funzionale
alla nostra esistenza e la nostra
sopravvivenza
e questo è il passato
oggi già vediamo che le colture sono un
po diverse
nel presente l'agricoltura è diventata
quasi un agricoltura industriale e
l'industria voi lo sapete ama pezzi
tutti uguali e quindi pezzi omogenei
cosa significa mere con la stessa forma
pomodori della stessa dimensione e
cetrioli con la stessa curvatura non è
mica colpa dell'europa s la curvatura
dei cetrioli deve essere in un certo
modo è necessario per le calibrazioni
per i processi di packaging
dei prodotti agroalimentari e poi
abbiamo bisogno di prodotti belli perché
mica possiamo andare al supermercato e
dire assaggio un'albicocca assaggio una
pesca saggio una banana no mica tanto
corretto
e allora cos'è che ci fa scegliere ci fa
scegliere l'estetica e quindi la
selezione negli ultimi anni è andato
verso varie tabelle e poi vogliamo
pagare sempre meno tutti noi noi
cerchiamo sempre l'offerta speciale e
quindi abbiamo bisogno di un'agricoltura
che produce a poco molto produttiva
rispetto agli input che noi ci mettiamo
e cosa perdiamo in questo ovviamente
perdiamo il gusto
nessuno interessato al gusto perché non
è un elemento discriminante futuro
abbiamo detto sedentari vecchi attenti
alla salute
beh io credo che avremo una agricoltura
molto ricca di colori ricca di verdura
ricca di frutti e molto probabilmente
scopriremo alimenti che abbiamo
abbandonato perché in passato non erano
utili ma adesso cominciano a diventare
utili perché sono ricchi di fattori
nutritivi nutraceutici che ci aiutano a
stare bene
3 miliardi di tonnellate di cereali
servono risorse e le risorse
lo sappiamo non sono infinite e oggi noi
non è che le usiamo benissimo stai
risorse molto si butta molto si spreca
anche dell'acqua si irriga quando non
serve tanto ce n'è ecco il futuro ci
chiede di diventare sostenibili e cosa
significa diventare sostenibili
significa diventare precisi
la risorsa la devo applicare nel momento
in cui serve deve rigare quando la
pianta sete allora ho bisogno di un
sensore ho bisogno di un drone che vada
a cercare dove stanno i parassiti nella
mia cultura per fare il trattamento lì
esattamente dove c'è il parassita e poi
ho bisogno di energia alternative in
agricoltura forse sole l'acqua il vento
sono più facili da integrare nel
processo rispetto a quello che avviene
in città e poi pensate quanti mestieri
in agricoltura sono pesanti faticosi
fatti in ambienti non può inospitali
pensate chi fa la cernita delle mele
temperature sono basse in piedi tutto il
giorno ecco che qui la sostenibilità
diventa sostenibilità sociale il robot
non va a rubare il lavoro ma va a
togliere quei lavori che sono faticosi
che sono pesanti e che ovviamente
nessuno ha piacere di fare e poi
suoniamo qualcuno ha detto dobbiamo
diventare tutti vegetariani se vogliamo
ridurre le emissioni e allora qualcuno
comincia a pensare anche a produrre la
carne in vitro
oggi siamo in grado di produrre tessuti
di cellule animali
completamente in vitro i costi sono alti
ma forse si abbasseranno quindi forse il
nostro hamburger avrà una parte o la
totalità di questi prodotti in vitro e
poi perché no anche altri alimenti ci
sono popolazioni che mangiano insetti
una cavalletta non è così distante da un
gamberetto però io mangio il gamberetto
non mangia la cavalletta e se pensavate
i bimbi
quante volte li abbiamo tolto la mosca
dalla bocca che stavano gustando con
grande piacere
ecco loro l'hanno già capita sono pronti
perché saranno la generazione futuro e
quindi loro hanno già capito che quella
potrebbe essere una possibilità e dopo
meno chimica
tutti abbiamo un po paura e chi di voi
non ha paura dei pesticidi questa cosa
subdola no che magari si fa fare qualche
fa venire qualche malattia che non
capiamo bene ce ne sono non ce ne sono
in realtà la nostra percezione e e molto
esagerata rispetto al rischio del
pesticida attualmente che sono prodotti
sicuri e testati attraverso processi
molto rigorosi però vogliamo meno
chimica perché la chimica di sintesi ha
effettivamente degli impatti e allora
dove cercare
gli strumenti e cerchiamoli nella natura
la natura
voi vedete a degli equilibri instabili
quindi c'è sempre una popolazione che
cresce i suoi nemici che la vanno a
contrastare allora perché non prendere
ad esempio i microrganismi che
contrastano le malattie natura isolarli
selezionarli produrre industrialmente e
sostituire quella molecola chimica del
pesticida con un microrganismo
naturalmente controlla la malattia
però poi si inserisce nell'ambiente si
degrada naturalmente possiamo anche
ridurre gli insetticidi e adesso vi
racconto una storia che è un po una
storia d'amore
gli insetti sono piccoli ma farfalle
sono piccoline immaginatevi una farfalla
in un frutteto e anche gli occhi sono
piccoli e trovarsi non è mica una cosa
facile
e qui l'evoluzione la natura è arrivata
in soccorso e le femmine producono delle
sostanze odorose si chiamano feromoni le
rilasciano i maschietti che volano qua e
là cercando appunto la femminuccia
percepiscono questa questa scia la
seguono
e a quel punto celano story l'amore si
accoppiano e nascono gli insetti
parassiti che poi andranno danneggiare
la nostra cultura ma se noi produciamo
questa stessa sostanza che è una
molecola naturale ma si può sintetizzare
ovviamente è la inseriamo dei diffusori
e la mettiamo noi frutteto e creiamo una
nuvola ovviamente sti poveri maschietti
sono un pochino
insomma persi un po confusi no perché
dov'è la traccia della femmina
se tutto questo questo fumo nodi
feromone
e quindi non si accoppiano e non nascono
poi le larghezza nuove e quindi noi
abbassiamo la popolazione naturalmente
senza insetticidi questo per circa 50
per cento degli insetti gli altri invece
cantano si fanno le serenate pensate ai
grilli le cicale no se la raccontano se
la cantano quante storie d'amore
sentiamo d'estate
ecco se noi riusciamo a creare nel
frutteto una vibrazione perché molti
vibrano non cantano non li percepiamo ma
si sentono tra di loro una vibrazione di
base di disturbo è un po come cercare di
parlarsi quando il volume della radio è
molto elevata
non ci si parla e allora siccome questi
insetti hanno bisogno di corteggiarsi
con queste canzoni e se non riescono a
parlarsi non si trovano non si
accoppiano e non nascono poi in futuro
la futura generazione di insetti e così
possiamo eliminare il problema
dell'insetticida
e quindi dopo tutta questa carrellata di
possibilità di cose future futuribili ma
anche attuali e l'agricoltura
tradizionale dove sta ci sarà sì ci sarà
assolutamente tutte queste innovazioni
tutti questi processi innovativi tutti
questi strumenti andranno a rendere
l'agricoltura tradizionale più forte più
sostenibile in modo tale che noi
possiamo mantenere il territorio
l'agricoltura un grosso ruolo sul
territorio possiamo mantenere la qualità
degli alimenti e vanno quando la nostra
amica qua dietro si chiede no
lecitamente ma io nel 2039 ci sarò beh
direi che la domanda la risposta a
questa domanda è sì ci sarò ancora
grazie
[Applauso]